european union leaders have announced
sanctions against belarus after it
forcibly diverted a ryanair flight and
arrested a dissident journalist the
measures were agreed on at a summit in
brussels
member states decided to take the
following steps well belarusian airlines
will be banned from using eu airspace
and
airports economic sanctions and
travel restrictions will be imposed on a
number of individuals linked to the
plains diversions
and a three billion euro eu investment
package for belarus will remain
on hold now the european council is
demanding the immediate release of
detained journalist roman pratseyevich
his supporters fear for his safety
this is the beginning of a highly
contested video
dissident journalist ramon partasievic
appears in front of a camera
after his detention by belarusian
authorities
the video was posted monday evening to a
pro-government social media channel
pataciewicz is saying that he is in good
health at the end of the video
he is quote confessing to organizing
mass disturbances
in minsk but patacievich's supporters
such as exiled opposition leader
svetlana tyranovskaya
believed the video was made under duress
he said
that he is being treated locally but he
is clearly beaten
and under pressure there is no doubt
that he may be tortured he was taken
hostage
the eu was firm in its response
introducing punitive measures against
the regime in minsk
top of the list banning belarusian
airlines from european skies
the eu is also slapping sanctions on
those responsible
for protesters abduction western powers
have widely condemned the incident
including nato the forced landing
of a passenger flight by belarus was
dangerous
and unacceptable this is a state
hijacking and demonstrates how the
regime means attacks
basic democratic rights on sunday
ramen protech was traveling from greece
to lithuania on orion airplane
the commercial flight he was on was
re-routed on its way to vilnius
and then escorted to minsk by a
belarusian warplane
allegedly because of a bomb threat but
no explosives were found on the aircraft
as a co-founder and former editor of the
nether channel on telegram
prataceevic used his influential voice
to royal alexander lukashenko's regime
he now faces up to 15 years in prison
let's take a closer look at this with
franco fertilka he's an advisor to
belarus his
opposition leader svetlana chikanovskaya
welcome to dw
um what do you make of this video
so i think he spent 24 hours in
lukashenko's custody in the hands of kgb
and he this confessed in the video
this this is the result of the uh
pressure of the psychological potential
the physical pressure
uh we know that kgb i saw this video
already in august and september when
thousands of billions got detained after
mass marches
and i must assure you that the
belarusian kgb can can force you to tell
whatever they want
right so as far as you're concerned this
is worthless because
this is a forced confession
exactly exactly and the good thing about
this that he is alive
we heard we heard and we saw that he is
alive
he is not very healthy and definitely
his uh
life is still under threat i think
rahman prathasevic is doing the
right thing when he is speaking what
they wanted him to say
otherwise he can be physically
intimidated always when we speak about
hostages safety
hostage must follow what the the
the criminal is doing our goal is to
release him as soon as possible
and to make sure that those who
who captured the hostage will pay high
price
how much do you think the eu's sanctions
will help to get him free
what we saw it was the wake-up call call
for international community for the
european union the united states
lukashenko was using the lack of
reaction from the west for many years
it created the feeling of impunity he
was arresting opponents he was cracking
down on
media he was detaining journalists and
right now after the plane situation
happened on sunday
we saw very quick reaction of brussels
of berlin and washington of london
this is a very good sign but only uh
closing the airspace is not enough it's
very important to isolate lukashenka's
regime
politically and diplomatically it's very
important that all perpetrators judges
prosecutors
all dues organize the special operation
they will be punished
and it's very important to discuss
economic sanctions but also
international investigation and tribunal
right so those would be your priorities
um and you would call on the eu to do
that
now or do or do would you like to see
them wait and see if this has
actually has any effect
we call on the eu to act now to act
quickly to act
bravely it's enough is enough lukashenka
shows that he
neglects all the rules all the
regulations
uh it's very good that eu reacted right
now but in order to stop the regime
the strong action joint effort needed
between all major stakeholders because
now it's not the domestic political
issue of belarus only
this is the threat to entire europe and
this is why
action isolation of the regime is
important
today thank you so much for for making
time for us belarusian opposition
advisor uh frank
facchoka
thank you well after last night's
meeting in brussels german chancellor
angela merkel dismissed
belarus's explanation of the incident
and had this message for the leadership
in minsk
must be released immediately all the
explanations for the first landing of
the ryanair flight are implausible
the same applies to his partner sophia
sapega we are demanding their release
zapiega more german reaction than from
andreas nick who is a member of the
german parliament for chancellor
merkel's christian democrats he also
sits on the parliament's
foreign affairs committee welcome to dw
um
will these sanctions from the eu cause
president lukashenko
to release mr president
well we certainly hope so we demand his
immediate release and
also that of sophia sabiga what we have
seen is i think an unprecedented violent
interference to
civil aviation in europe by a state
actor
some have even described it as an act of
state terrorism i think this is totally
unacceptable
we must be very strict and very clear in
our response to make sure that we don't
see contagion
of that kind of behavior to other
authoritarian regimes
around the world this is totally
unacceptable it was the interception of
a flight between
the capitals of two eu and two nato
member states
and this uh deserves the the clearest
and strictest response
uh possible but here's the thing about
that that response
you've all the eu already has sanctions
against uh
against uh belarus nothing has happened
there is
nothing about the sanctions there is
nothing about the actions of
of president lukashenko that it gives
any indication that
sanctions will have any effect so where
does this hope
that this will help to bring about the
the relief of
release of mr president had come from
i think the the required release of mr
porter
and his uh his girlfriend is is one
thing but we also need to be absolutely
clear in uh counteracting against that
violent interference into international
air travel we have now de facto turned
belarus into a civilian no-fly zone
within 24 hours
airspace is closed civilian airliners
from
western europe will not uh go to minsk
anymore
we've asked for an ikea investigation
and and i think this is a very strict
first response i think
in the second step we will have to
target state enterprises
to a more severe extent whether it's in
energy or chemicals or other industrial
sectors
i think there is still scope for uh very
clear messages and clear measures
towards belarus
belarus has now really made itself the
ultimate rogue state
in europe it is the only state not
eligible for membership in the council
of europe because it maintains
the death penalty which may hopefully
not be an issue in this
specific context as far as mr proceed
which is concerned
but this is totally unacceptable this is
an interference into
sovereignty of eu member states and nato
member states and we need to be as clear
as possible in our response
i'd like to get your reaction to
something that we we heard uh yesterday
from uh britain's uh a foreign uh
minister
uh dominican rabb he said it's very
difficult to believe that this kind of
action
would have been taken without without at
least the acquiescence of the
authorities
in moscow i wonder do you also
believe russia to be involved in this
i have no specific evidence for that but
i think there is a lot of plausibility
that
also operationally this may not be
something that belarus has done
on their own and we hear
concerning messages from moscow in this
whole regard we understand that mr
lukashenko
is in the hands of of of the kremlin and
has their
their backing but we also need to make
clear that this comes at a cost
uh to everyone involved as well good
talking to you thank you so much for
joining us andreas nick from uh
the german parliament's foreign affairs
committee
thank you